okay a guy has a kid with you and this
kid comes out butt ugly because you got
all this plastic surgery done now this
man has to deal with an ugly kid because
you got to be honest about what you
looked like or like imagine you take a
girl home from the bar take her clothes
off it's a waist trainer now you've I
mean obviously he's gonna sleep with you
because he's there because you're there
but but that's a modern day probably and
this is why it's important to meet the
family because
any guy that marries a girl has a kid to
go without actually meeting her family
whatever he gets his own human because
even when you meet the family you can
still end up losing so imagine doing all
that without even meeting the family